d'autres aventures tourisme fluvial
commence dans un port celui de savoie
yeux à noël albert le grand père qui a
huit vallorbe en suisse a offert une
semaine de bateaux à toute sa famille au
total dix personnes et le chien jeu
plutôt montagne me met vraiment là c'est
des moments qu'on croirait record en
amazonie l'amazone il y aurait des
bouilles en aucune habitation la saône
par omeyer comme ça génial alors
direction la masoni ça donne envie
c'est stéphane qui nous emmène au bout
du monde
d'habitude il reste à quai pour gérer
l'entreprise familiale de location et
réparation de bateaux ses clients
cherchent sur la saône ce qu'ils ne
trouvent pas ailleurs
l'intérêt c'est voilà de faire de la
balade bucolique et
de déstresser de prendre du bon temps
par rapport à la vie de tous les jours
comme chacun le sait on est stressé en
permanence donc ici en consentant un
temps qui s'écoule tranquillement au fil
de l'eau j'ai toujours rêvé de faire du
tourisme fluvial fluvial comme fleuve
comme une promesse d' océans d'infini
même si la somme n'est qu'une rivière
elle permet de se la couler douce je
joue même au capitaine vous allez
prendre la barre catherine et vous allez
voir que ça se conduit très facilement
vous restez là quand même hein je suis à
côté de vous
[Musique]
un autre voyage nous attend un voyage
dans le temps cette fois ci grâce au
château de ré sur saône vieux de dix
siècles ont dit au revoir et merci à
stéphane et on suit le guide
yves krattinger le président du conseil
départemental
diane de salle verte la dernière
propriétaire a donné deux châteaux et
tout ce qu'il contient à la haute saône
et à ses habitants sur la vallée de la
saône
il n'y a pas meilleur phare
touristiquement ya pas meilleur fars il
est au dessus de la vallée la au bail à
la zone un lieu touristique majeure
la restauration de cet édifice coûtera
plus de 5 millions d'euros
mais cet investissement va beaucoup plus
loin qu'une simple rénovation de
patrimoine c'est de donner de la fierté
aux habitants ça c'est une à
quelques-uns en france très peu qui sont
meublées comme ça c'est à eux désormais
c'est aux habitants
c'est le lieu de la fierté la
haute-saône relève la tête et de il faut
qu'elle soit fière de ce qu'elle a parce
qu'on ne peut se vendre
que sait on est fier de ce qu'ont fait
de ce qu'on a de ce qu on offre aux
autres fier ce vésulien est fier de son
département et de ce coin de paradis
qu'il a créé il ya vingt ans entre ciel
terre et où quand vous avez un
hébergement ici à sun valley vous avez
un canoë barques pédalos ou
éventuellement des bateaux ou un moteur
sans permis pour partir sur la saône
au départ on était vraiment sur terre
avec les chalets sur terre comme une
petite marina loisirs et aujourd'hui on
est sur l'eau pourrait être aussi dans
l'hébergement insolite mais en tout
confort
[Musique]
pressés à cantonner en bateau pour
passer quand un bateau mais faut pas
être pressé non que quand on est en
vacances 7 buts
mais voilà le temps qui m'était imparti
est maintenant terminée alors en
accéléré on passe une excuse on
s'enfonce dans le tunnel de saint-alban
où il fait bon frais et on se croit en
amazonie oui je prendrai le temps de
revenir et je ferai encore du bateau sur
la saône
merci au revoir